hi guys I hope you're ready for lesson
five in this lesson what we'll be
covering is how we can actually host our
AI application online using just python
uh we're going to do away with any
complexity in terms of managing servers
or any configurations uh all we all we
need to do is use something called
streamlit which is great for AI
applications and data science and we can
basically host our app on there for free
using just python then what we're going
to be doing is publishing our we're
going to be using streamlit to actually
publish the AI application we've started
building which is the tool for analyzing
CAD PDFs and creating bill of quantities
from uh those PDFs we then going to look
at Access Control how we can limit who
actually can gain access to our
application and how we handle the API
Keys making sure that we're not being
build uh unnecessarily for people who
are using our application
okay so we're once again back on our
notion training resources page and what
I want you to do is go to lesson five so
we're going to open this lesson up and
what we're going to do is we're going to
first uh go to streamlit and I'm going
to explain exactly what streamlit is so
streamlet is basically um an online
service for hosting data applications
using just python what's great about
this is that we don't need to handle
other programming languages in order to
build our front end typically uh your UI
your ux all of this stuff um you might
have to use something like JavaScript or
you might have to use HTML CSS all of
these other Concepts or other languages
in programming um what's great about uh
streamlit is that we don't have to do
that we can just use Python and uh they
will be able to cre we'll be able to
create front-end applications and user
interface just using python so I really
like this because it's really well
supported and um really good for AI
applications they have a lot of
libraries that are really useful um so
what we're going to do is we're going to
get signed into this it's completely
free everything we're going to do with
streamlet today and in our lessons is
going to be completely
free so after you've got signed in um we
don't have to do anything here right now
um we've created our account what I'm
going to show you next is about setting
up our GitHub so what we also have to do
is we also have to set up a GitHub now
what GitHub is is it's actually a um
it's actually a tool for managing all of
your code so uh if you imagine what
we've been doing so far with our other
lessons we've been building uh scripts
if you imagine you have multiple people
working on this application editing
files editing different lines of code
and you uh both potentially working on
the same block of code at the same time
you can have real issues when you both
go to then push that code or deploy it
because you've both changed the same
thing and it will get very confusing and
very messy so rather than just saving
your code in a way in which you might
like a word file or a file on your Shar
company drive with code you want to
manage it in a different way you want to
allow some checking of uh what what
could be conflicting what could be uh
what's changed each time it's being
updated if you imagine if you imagine
you're running some really important
operation like Financial uh company like
a bank um and you you know you you
making so there's some error in the
lines of code you don't just want to be
able to save that you want to be able to
like review it and check it before it
gets deployed so what GitHub does is it
sort of facilitates all of that handling
and management of code so what we uh
like there's alternatives to this
there's an alternative called gitlab
which is quite similar um in this in
these demos what we're going to be doing
is uh using GitHub though um this is
going to be the way in which we link our
streamlit to our code which we're
actually going to be writing so what I
want you to also do at this point is to
create a GitHub account you don't have
to do anything with that right now but I
just want you to get to a page that
looks a bit like this um after
registering you should be taken here and
um yeah and then I want you to just
leave it like this so you've just signed
in and I also want you to have just
signed in in streamlit nothing else just
to have to just to have signed in okay
next thing I want you to do is I want
you to come over to your notion uh
training page again and I want you to
download this new application which
we're going to be building it's a zip
file and I want you to download this one
and I want you to store it wherever you
like to store these these things so I'm
going to just put this one on my desktop
for now but feel free to put it anywhere
you want um and we're going to be
working from this so this is going to be
our project folder now so if you
remember from our last lesson what I
want you to do is I want you to go to vs
Studio code I want you to open a new
window for vs Studio code and I want you
to go to file open folder and we're
going to go to where this new folder is
which is going to be in our blueprint
analysis app which is on my desktop so I
just want you to click open and then you
should see something a bit like this so
you'll see on the left a folder named
stream do streamlet sample blueprints
Blueprints and requirements.txt don't
worry too much about what all of these
mean right now but just um just double
check that your your project folder
should look like this
structure next I want you to go back to
uh back to our notion page and you see
here following the instructions down
what we now want to do is we want to
open our terminal so what we're going to
be doing here is we already touched on
this a little bit when I was showing you
about installing open AI open AI on our
jupyter notebook but what we're going to
be doing here is setting up our
environment so I want you to click
terminal and click new
terminal the thing I'll say about this
before we get started actually one of
the most tricky things one of the most
uh problematic uh yeah problematic
things and timec consuming things is
always setting up environments I'm not
sure why but every time you need to do
some coding setting up environments can
be quite tricky so I don't want you to
feel intimidated about these different
commands that we're going to be running
now because um you know even even for
people who have been doing it for a long
time uh working with different
environments can be quite tricky so what
we're going to do is we're going to set
up our environment in our in our folder
here blueprints blueprint analysis app
so we're going to set this up so that we
can run code in here um and what I want
to do is I want to go back to my notion
and I want to make sure okay you should
make sure first that python is installed
uh we should have done that in the last
lesson so if you skipped ahead make sure
that you have python installed and what
we're going to do is we're going to
create our um virtual environment so
while this is is running I'm just going
to explain what a virtual environment
actually is so a virtual environment is
essentially like a small container
within your overall computer and that's
what I'm doing here is I'm setting up
the this folder as being that container
what this container will cont what will
contain is going to be these different
libraries that we're installing so if
you imagine I'm opening this I'm
installing this open AI Library I
probably don't want to install that
across my entire computer
um because it might conflict with
another piece of code that I'm trying to
do in another area of uh because
sometimes it could be different versions
perhaps you've got another app that uses
a much older version that's not
compliant with with the new openai
library so what you want to do is set up
a small container within your computer
where you're actually going to be
installing this stuff so you're not
installing it across your whole uh your
entire
computer so that's just for better
management so what I've done here is
I've actually created the virtual
environment within that folder and what
I'm going to do here is I'm actually
going to activate that virtual
environment so you can tell that a
virtual environment is not created
because it will just have uh nothing
nothing at the start of this but if we
watch here you're going to see this
change now so we suddenly have this v m
appearing each time and we never had
that before so what this means to me is
that the virtual environment is now
activated um and this the these uh
liaries that we install in here are not
going to be installed on my whole
computer when we're using Jupiter
notebook um that has its own sort of
container so when we were running those
scripts it wasn't uh it wasn't going to
install across my whole computer so what
we have here is the virtual environment
running next what I want to do is
install streamlit so this is a library
we're going to be using by streamlet
themselves and this is the way in which
you create applications that you then
push uh push onto the internet push onto
streamlet to be hosted so I actually
installed this which is going to give me
all of the functions that streamlet use
in order to build um applications to
build web applications so you see it
installs quite a lot it's actually quite
like a heavy um Library obviously
because it's pretty complicated what
they're doing uh in terms of turning
python into uh web websites so um this
is going to be installing it might take
a little bit longer and then what I'm
going to do is I'm actually after this
is installed is I'm going to do
streamlit run and then the name of my
python file which is inside um inside
the project that we've downloaded so you
see here blueprints um o this is
actually a spelling mistake so this
should actually be blueprints here so
I'm going to copy this across so
streamlit run blueprint stop P so you
see here it's fully installed um next
line is available so I'm going to now
run this and this is actually going to
use the streamlet library to actually
run my application we're going to see
what happens here but I think I might
need to probably install some libraries
before I'm allowed to do
this oh no I can run it straight away so
what you'll see here up uh it's opened
up my browser and it's now running on a
local host so this is like a local
server that my computer has created uh
so it functions a little bit like a
website I can open Chrome and I can uh
visit this website but this isn't on the
this isn't on the web this isn't on the
internet this is just like running on my
own local computer this is the way in
which if you're doing web development
you'll often work on the Local Host
while you're while you're changing the
code and you just push it onto the web
once you're once you're happy with it
once you've got it up to a good state
so you'll see here it took a little
while to get set up the first time but
we've actually loaded this all up fine
now um which is really cool so we
already have the the the basic template
for what we're going to be doing but let
me let me talk you through this
blueprint. py now so what you'll see
here is um okay we've installed
streamlet we also um need to install
open AI but I believe I probably
actually have this installed over my
whole computer rather than um rather
than just in a virtual environment so
this has actually worked just straight
away for me um and then these are all
Native to um to uh python so we've
already got these through already like
base 64 Etc so you don't have to install
these that's the reason why um I was
able to run this straight away but what
you might need to do is run pip install
open AI so I'll just show you that first
if it didn't work straight away and you
have an error message here say
uh you don't have open AI installed um
you can actually run this command what
this will say to me now is it will
either update open AI or it will
actually um or it will actually tell me
it's already
installed okay so yeah basically you see
it's installed um we're going to do
stream that run blueprints Pi anyway so
we're just going to get this back up and
I'm just going to explain exactly what
this is doing here
so what we have if we sort of scroll
through this
slowly um and I explain on a high level
is we have our python code that we were
actually using before so there's some
elements that you'll recognizing here
things like message content um type text
and we have this provid a takeoff of the
quantities of this engineering uh
drawing you know so some of this we
recognize um in here but it also looks
very different as well you see here CL
in open AI this is some of the stuff we
were already doing in our previous
script but what has changed here is we
actually have a lot of this these St
dots St dot so what you'll see here is
this is the streamlet library that we're
using and what the the great thing about
this about streamlit is that I I'm
actually building the website um as I'm
going through the code so it reads in
the same way as you would read standard
python but what you actually have here
is um elements being created on the
website so on that web app so if you see
here um let's just take this one first
St markdown um this uh hashtag and then
CAD blueprint takeoff AI so basically
what this is doing here is it's creating
me um markdown is a form of uh
formatting for blogs actually mainly but
um
you can create headings with it so what
I'm doing here is basically saying St I
want to add some markdown text and this
symbol just means that this is going to
be like a heading it's uh going to be
this title
style what I can do here is just to just
to sort of prove a point to you guys is
I can also add um just some extra words
here so let me use my Microsoft co-pilot
to just create another block down here
which is this AI will TR to take off
quantities from engineering drawings
returning only a table was marked down
so let me save this and let's see what
happens over here we might need to
refresh and you see we've just added
this block of text in here adding a bit
more information on what this
applications
doing so this is the way in which we
work with streamlet we can just
basically build out a web app here uh
with python which is really nice and
it's very well supported and free
which is always good and so um here here
is another interesting thing so what
we're doing here is we're creating a
text input and we're setting it to a
variable here let me just see what
happens if I remove this API key part uh
maybe we can't do that
actually let me let me show you another
example here where I actually create
another text
input so what what you're going to see
here is another box appear just above
openi API um but have to give it a
different
name
um so what we're basically doing here is
creating a text input with this block
here so text St text input allows us to
create a block and we're calling this a
password but that just means that it's
going to appear in this way
but what we're doing here is we're
actually setting this to a variable so
what this means is rather than just us
adding information to the to the um to
the front end uh adding like components
let's say to the front end in this case
what we're actually doing here is we're
setting it to a variable that we can use
further down in our application in in
the python code so um here what we've
done is we've created our we've we've
gathered our API key which
we're going to collect from the user
from them typing it in so the thing here
is the reason why this is will be fine
to publish online is that what we're
doing here is we're setting this up so
that the user can come with their own
API key they're not going to be using
our uh using our API key uh that we've
already set up but you you you can feel
free to actually add your own API key on
the back end but you just need to make
sure that this is probably private or
it's only being shared with people that
you trust or have authenticated in some
way um and have perhaps paid some
service for you for them to use uh your
your credits so just be very mindful of
that when you're setting this up that
you um around handling the API Keys
we'll talk a little bit more about that
though now what we're doing is we're
saying um basically if so we're having a
send button so below um oh no let me
talk about this first so image input so
we what we have here is another
component which is file
uploader so this is a kind of drag and
drop boox or um click to upload files
and what we're doing here is we using
the the streamlit documentation to
accept multiple files so we don't just
have one we we can actually allow
multiple to be uploaded here and this is
of type
images as file uploader um we're going
to accept images here and um we're
setting that as being image input equal
image input so we can use both of these
in our application and so far in our
application these are the only two
inputs we're using so we're just taking
the API key the image input and this is
what we're going to use through
throughout our app so what we're now
doing is we're both creating a send
button and listening if this send
button's being pressed so this is very
smart way of actually um the streamlit
team like having built this in my
opinion so you're saying that you know
if this St button is pressed you're
going to execute all this information
all these lines of code in here and in
the in the python uh syntax you're
having this indent here which is um you
know the standard for if statements
you're going to indent all that code
below really important to do the intent
indenting correctly in Python it's like
a fundamental part so you see here this
is a simple um in terms of how it works
you're you're having this if uh if the
send button pressed you can execute all
this so if you don't have the API key so
what we're doing here is a check like if
your API key is none so if you haven't
typed anything in here what we're going
to do is we're actually going to set a
warning message so we're going to tell
the user they can't do this because your
API key is required so we're rendering
this warning message down here um with
stopping this uh these lines of code
from executing any further so again this
is another streamlit function where
we're saying okay Escape Escape
everything else that's going to happen
below and just stop the
application um then what we're doing uh
this will look very familiar is uh we're
basically setting up our message which
we're going to send to openai so this is
uh from the open openai documentation
this is how you create your message uh
in which uh you're going to send which
you're going to attach to the uh CL
openai client object and you're going to
send uh this is the response uh in here
so you see here messages uh message is
in there and we're with we're initiating
or creating this up here and then adding
our image a bit further down so what
we've got here is just the the text uh
to explain what this uh what we're going
to do when we send the API request what
we want open AI to do so we're creating
an images uh an images object here or an
images uh list I guess this will be yeah
it's going to be a list and then um what
we're doing is then iterating so we're
doing the loop here so for image in
image input so this could be multiple
remember we could have multiple in here
which is why we're doing this
Loop um we're getting our each image and
we're basically doing a check here to
make sure it is definitely an image so
what we don't want to do is we don't
want to try to uh send some other types
of files um perhaps someone's going to
upload some uh DWG file for example or
an IFC file and we actually haven't
built this to accept those uh we'd have
to do some other type of processing
probably if we want to try and do that
so what we're doing here is just a final
check which is for making sure the file
type is like JP Peg PNG we're only doing
images right now rather than PDFs but
you can imagine you can also um you can
also work with PDFs in this just have to
convert them into base 64 format uh so
an image format before you send them uh
and then what we're doing is yeah this
encoding this will look very familiar
from the last lesson where we're
creating our base 64 objects from each
image so We're looping through each
image in the image input so it could be
multiple encoding each one we're then
appending so to this list of images up
here we're appending each image and then
what we're doing is adding this um to
the message content so append command if
you remember this one uh we're basically
going into this this um this um
dictionary which is going to be sent so
content is one element of the dictionary
one key of the
and then we're appending in there one of
the images and then this is going to be
that base 64 uh binary data which we're
then going to be sending to the openai
API then what we're doing is we're
setting up our client this is the same
as what we were doing in jupyter
Notebook uh set up our client setting up
the response and following the AP openai
documentation in terms of how we create
this um this is some extra stuff we
didn't have in the last time which is
basically your setting the temperature
this is how temperature is how much you
want the uh this model to be flexible so
uh open AI have allowed temperature to
be how creative it can be so we set this
as zero so it's as strict as possible
it's not going to try and give us
something creative it's just going to
stick to whatever task we've given it in
terms of this prompt up here so it's
going to just follow this it's not going
to try and guess what we might be
meaning or reading between between the
lines we set our tokens this is the way
you can control perhaps you can control
spend um so how much do you want each
query to actually end up sort of costing
you so this is more from like perhaps a
commercial point of view um how much do
you want to uh use but you can also
think of this as a way of like setting
some succinctness as well if you don't
set too many tokens and you ask this to
be cinct you'll get quite short
answers and then here's obviously the
messages we're adding then what we're
doing is we we're uh associating some
response message variable as being
whatever comes from this response so
we're waiting for this response when we
get it we're then reading out um
following the open AI documentation
reading out that message we're getting
back we're then displaying this uh
message that we've received so right now
this is just in memory in the in this
application so you're not going to be
able to see anything here on the user
perspective so when what you're doing is
you're reading this displaying this to
the user with this St chat message so
they in the sense that like streamlet is
very good for developing some AI
applications this is one for like
displaying chat messages here acting as
the user um and uh likewise you know if
you have this response message which is
this one you're reading this out as the
assistant so really nice like just out
of the box for Crea in these um chat
chat functions so what we're doing here
is we're basically um looking through
this open a um object that's being sent
back so this is actually just basically
from the streamlit documentation of how
to build these uh chat Bots basically
with um using using these uh different
objects and then we're writing out this
text within this within this chat box so
this is basically Al what's happening
here we're just writing out some text
and um we're also re writing out the
images so um with those images we're
actually going to add those into this as
well so we're going to see both the text
and the images and then we're going to
see below that this assistant response
so let's try and run this shall we after
this long explanation so we're already
uh we've already got this live let's
just double check so I can double check
this by clicking uh like new terminal
this is just the way I do it and then
you'll see here if it's still running or
not server still running so let's go
to let's go first to make sure we have
our open I key API key so again we're
going to want to copy this um in to our
application and we're going to go to
copy our key in here we're going to add
some of our images so let's get our
image from inside here we have some
sample blueprints let's just have a look
this one will look familiar and what
we're going to do is we're going to drag
and drop this into images so you see
here this is loaded and now let's send
and see what we get
back so you'll see up in the top right
it's saying that it's running and it
could take a little bit of time because
it's not streaming but here we've got it
back so yes once again we have our list
of our bill of quantities okay the next
thing we want to do is we actually want
to publish this online so we want to
turn this Local Host URL into a URL
which looks much more like other
websites where we can actually other
people can come and uh connect onto our
website and visit it so what we want to
do here is we want to go back to our
notion training page and we just want to
follow what's going to be the next
instruction so what I see here is that
we need to create a GitHub repository by
clicking new repository and make sure
it's public so let's go over to our
GitHub so we've already uh registered
and signed in and what we want to do
here is we want to create a repository
with this green button up here so what a
repository is is it's
a place or a folder let's say think
maybe you could think of it as a folder
or an archive where we basically store
code so when we're working on a project
it could be a website it could be a
phone application it could be anything
um we're going to store all of that code
in a repository where other people can
be invited to come in we can collaborate
we can start working together and the
important thing here is you might be
working on different projects so some
might be an open source project some
might be private some might be with uh
one company some might be with another
company so what you you do is you create
repositories where people can come and
they can work together and we can do all
this for free GitHub um for at least
getting started and for most purposes is
free so um what we want to do here is
this is my GitHub account and what I
want to do is create a new repository
here so what I'm going to call it is
completely up to you but I would call it
just so you follow along let's call it
blueprint AI
uh so this is available so I can call it
this um and I want to leave everything
else basically the same so I'm making
this a public I'm making this a public
archive so anyone can on the internet
can see this
repository um you could also make this
private but I'll suggest making it just
public um for you to be able to follow
along but this will mean it's open
source so you might want to change that
in the future if if you're thinking
about um you know uh working on some
more private private subjects so uh I'm
going to keep this public to start with
just for the course and I'm going to
create this repository now so this will
take a few seconds probably to actually
create my repository and here it is so
blueprint Ai and it's open to the
public um there's a few things you can
do here you can like St people could
people like to Star different open
source projects um if they like them so
you can add a star um and there's yeah a
lot of features get H really has a lot
of features and we're only going to
scratch really scratch the surface here
um really not going into too much detail
on everything but this is going to be
our repository for blueprint Ai and
you're going to be able to find this on
the internet so what I'm going to do
here is I'm going to go back to my
notion and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to copy that URL from Quick
setup um but actually what I'm going to
do before that is I'm going to do some
other things so this is actually in the
wrong slightly wrong order what I'm
going to do is I'm going
to first go to vs code and I'm going to
type get in it so what this is going to
do get in it as it's going to initialize
so it's going to create a git uh
repository of on my local F in my local
folder so you won't be able to see it
here um but you'll see this message here
saying initialized empty git repository
in here in in my folder so what this is
going to do and you'll see all these
files have suddenly turned green apart
from blueprints stpy so what this is uh
doing is it's like tracking uh what's
changing now so this is going to be how
I actually Connect into GitHub and I'm
going to push all my files git this git
repository you might need to check
though that you actually have git
installed so if you run this you might
actually run into um an error and you
need to basically download um git onto
your computer so you can you can go to
um this uh this link and you can
download either from Mac OS Windows you
want to download and install this after
you've installed uh git you this command
will work and you will be able to follow
the next steps so what I now want to do
is I want to type in git add dot so it's
very short um
short uh command um and this is just one
step towards telling git that you're
basically adding uh some information to
this empty it's empty to start with but
you're adding going to be adding some
information to it so each time you want
to push new code to GitHub you're going
to want to type in git add and then this
full stop then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to type in git commit um and
I'm going to call this git commit
message initial commit so what this is
basically doing is it
um actually this is taking a little
longer the next thing that we want to do
is we actually want to host our
application on the web so we want to
turn this Local Host URL into a proper
URL uh that people can visit uh in their
web browsers and they come come and use
our application so the way in which
we're going to do this we're going to
basically push this uh application code
onto streamlit uh and use their hosting
services so the way in which we're going
to do that is we're going to go back to
our notion training page we're going to
follow the next instruction so next
instruction is basically we need to go
to GitHub we need to click new
repository and list that new repository
as public so I'm going to go back to my
GitHub where I've just got signed in and
I'm going to go to new so I'm going to
find this green button and what I'm
going to do is I'm going to click this
and create a new repository so a
repository is basically a place where
you can come and you can store your code
so it could be thought of like as like
an archive live or a folder um and this
is going to be a place where you store
one Project's code so as a as a
developer you could be working on many
different projects you could be working
on an open- source project another Clos
source project you could be working with
like multiple different companies or
clients and so you're going to want to
store all of that code separately um and
allow people to be invited to come and
collaborate and work on these different
projects with you together so GitHub has
all of this
built in uh so it facilitates all of
this so what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to create a new
repository uh and when I click uh that
new button I'm going to be taking
through to this page to sort of set that
up um and I have some different options
here so the first thing I can do is I
can give this repository a name so
perhaps I want to call this
blueprints um
analysis
app uh and then I want to basically
double check uh so I want this to be a
public project so this is quite
important because uh if I'm making this
public it means anyone on the internet
can come and they can see this
repository um you can choose though who
who uh can actually commit an update
make updates to your codebase here so
when you update a codebase you commit
you commit to that codebase um and you
update the code there so you're still in
control of who can do that but anyone
can actually come and see this
repository what you might like to do in
the future is you might like to make
some of this private where you're you're
working on the code base yourself you're
adding some proprietary information
there you don't want that to be exposed
to people on the internet so you can
make this private if you wish we're
going to leave this public for now and
we're going to click create repository
down here so we're going to get this set
up so our repository is now
created um and what we want to do so as
you see GitHub has many different
features we're only just scratching the
surface of what you can really do with
GitHub um lot of lot of features here
and there's some instructions here
basically on how you can how you can get
a set up and we're actually going to be
um we're actually going to be doing this
method but we're just going to follow
along with the um we're going to follow
along with the notion page but you
actually have some instructions here of
how to get set up so I'm going to go
back to notion
and then I'm going to follow some of
these uh new instructions so um next
line is basically I need to go back into
my vs code I need to go to the terminal
again and I'm going to type in this
command git
init so this git init command is
actually going to um it's actually going
to create a local git repository on in
this folder so I'm going to initialize
in it is initialize git a git repository
and empty git repository in this project
folder so as it turns out I've actually
already created a a git repository here
so it's just reinitializing it but you
should uh you should have receive a
message that basically says that you
create you've just created the git
repository um if you get an error
message here some of you might not have
git installed on your computer so you'll
get an error message if you try and run
that so what you need to do is go to
step 14 and basically download git if if
you haven't already so you need to
download the Mac OS version or the
windows version depending on what you're
working with um get that installed um
and then rerun that get init command and
it should be all
good uh next I want to follow the the
next instruction in the list and that is
I want to run this git ad a so this is
basically telling this git repository
that I'm about to make a change um so it
basically means I'm I'm making a change
to this skit repository and that has
just run so I'm on the new line okay now
what I want to do is I want to grab this
next line from here which is git commit
M initial push and I want to copy that
to the clipboard and what this is going
to do is it's um is it's I'm going to
paste this into the command line here
and what this is uh what git commit does
is it Associates uh so it commits my
code and then it also provides a message
so you should always try and add a
descriptive message onto what your
commit is um to help other developers if
you're working with other de developers
to understand what the meaning of this
uh commit was so what feature you've
changed uh what's what's the meaning of
this uh block of work you've just done
so help them with uh like reviewing your
code um but here I'm just naming this
initial push and then I'm going to hit
enter
uh and what I need to do is I need to do
get add a so I think I made some other
change uh and then initial push so uh
what you'll see here is basically I've
done my push um and you'll get some
message down here basically saying
what's changed or what's been added um
and next what I want to do is I want
to actually add this command here uh
sorry I want to actually go to GitHub
first and I'm going to want to copy I
want to copy this this part here get
remote at
origin uh into the command line down
here get remote at origin and then I
want to go to GitHub and I want to copy
this code here so if you follow these
instructions it would be very similar uh
what you're actually doing here um so
I'm going to copy this which is the URL
for this for this repository so
blueprints analysis app and I'm going to
add that to the end of this git remote
at origin this is linking going to link
my local git so this uh folder to this
GitHub
repository so my GitHub repository I'm
going to send this code up
into uh that that GitHub repository so
here what I need to do is I'm going to
go back to notion and I'm going to copy
this block of code here which is git
push origin main so there's a branch um
basically in GitHub you can work on
branches or with Git you work on
branches and so you could have the main
branch or the master branch and people
will do other branches off of that and
then push work on some certain branch of
code and then push it back to the main
branch where people will review it and
make sure it's correct before you merge
it in so the idea there is you that's
where you do lots of debugging and
making sure that all of the code is uh
working uh in harmony so I'm going to
now push this though to the main branch
so I'm pushing it straight to the to the
main branch rather than a sub Branch um
just because basically it's just me
working on this at the moment
so uh if you look here you see some some
kind of processing has been happening
compressing objects writing objects and
this is basically it being sent up to
GitHub and then it it's up there so it's
saying like uh it's been sent to the
main branch so what I can do now is I
can go back to my repository and I can
refresh this and see how this looks now
so we'll see our code has arrived on
GitHub and what we do is we have all of
this up there being stored um including
our environment variables which I'm not
sure if it's actually best for us to
have like pushed those up there but
anyway um we have it all we have it all
on GitHub now so what we can do next is
um because it's already here we're just
going to go straight into streamlit now
so we have our streamlit account and we
need to make sure this is linked to
GitHub so I already have mine linked
down here but you might have to click
some button um depending on where the UI
uh where the UI is like the time when
you're doing this but you need to
connect your GitHub to uh stream lip
it's really easy to do um and just sign
in um and authenticate and then once
you've done that you can click this
create app button you click this create
app button and you'll see uh you have
this message deploy an app what
repository are you going to work from so
in here I've got a bunch of different
repositories um um and I want to click
this blueprints analysis app repository
so this is the one we've just been
working on which branch are we on we're
on the main branch there's only one and
we're going to say which is the main
file path so this path does not exist so
what what file do we want to use here so
we're going to go here and we're going
to see oh it's our blueprints dopy file
is our main application so what we're
going to do is we're going to rename
this blueprints Pi this is been found
great and now we're going to do deploy
and we're going to cross our fingers and
hope that everything uh deploys uh
nicely we have no
errors uh so yeah it seems it seems
something's working so you can actually
click this manage app button and sort of
see what's going on as well uh so this
is like a log of uh what's happening so
let's see this is this is working away
and in the mean time python dependencies
have been installed so those different
python dependencies we were using have
all been installed which is
great mhm and it looks like it may work
process dependencies so yeah we've
everything has worked
nicely and this is our URL so this is
now live on the web you could go on your
phone or um on a different browser on a
different computer type this in I know
it's quite an ugly URL to start with but
you could replace this with your own um
and now I can actually get my open a key
once again and let's verify that this is
actually all working so we're going to
put our API key in here we're going to
go to our
application we're going to go to our uh
blueprint analysis app get one of our
blueprints uh drag this
in and hit send let's see what
happens let's see if it works straight
away and it's all good yes so we've
we've got our image here our our uh
blueprint that we can see we see our
prompt that we sent off and below this
we've got the readout of our um our
quantities so everything's worked we've
just deployed our first AI construction
app onto the web so great job if you
followed along I know once again this
was a difficult lesson um uh but I hope
this is very rewarding for you to have
deployed your first AI application on
the internet so great job okay great job
guys I know that we covered once again a
lot in this lesson and please do go back
and rewatch any sections and feel free
to pause and double check and message in
the Discord group if there's anything
that was confusing or unusual in this
lesson um and I'll do my best to support
and help out uh in the so in the next
lesson what we're going to be doing is
we're going to take all this stuff we've
learned and we're going to like multiply
it basically so we're going to add a bit
more to this app we've currently been
working on for analyzing Blueprints and
CAD drawings um we're also going to do
uh another app which is going to be for
civil engineering which is going to turn
site photographs into a word report so
similar to the custom GPT we created
earlier we're going to do that but in
your own web app so you can do more
customization and add more features to
it uh the one the thing after that is
we're going to do one for contractors
where we're going to be a to analyze
Construction contract risk and write up
a table of the of the main risks and
severity of the different risks in the
con ruction contract and create a draft
renegotiation email and then finally
we're going to do a really exciting one
which is for I guess this is my personal
favorite one actually even though it's
for I guess more Architects um but it
could be for anyone designing their own
house or interior design which is is
going to take uh photos of buildings and
rooms and restyle them so you can take a
very traditional looking room or
building and modernize it or change
between different architectural styles
so we're going to also build this as
your own app so hope you're looking
forward to the next lesson is going to
be the culmination of everything